من ابواب خلفيه تلتف روسيا على عقوبات
الغرب على نفطها لطالما تجد من يفتح لها
تلك الابواب عبر المحيطات
علمتني سفن بحريه تبحر شحنات النفط
الروسيه ووفقا لسين ان فان اعدادها هذه
السفن تتزايد التقديرات تشير الى ان اسطول
سفن يحمل النفط الروسي مكون من 600 سفينه
اي بنسبه عشره في المئه من العدد الاجمالي
للناقلات البحريه الكبيره حول العالم في
الظل وعن بعد دخل لاعبون جدد لملئ فراغ
الغرب الصين والهند وتركيا ابرز
المستوردين للنفط الروسي وصادرات موسكو
تسجل مستوى قياسيا في يناير وفقا لشركه
كيبلر للبيانات والاحصات
وبعيدا عن اعين الرادارات والرياح
العقوبات تسير السفن التي يظل تحديدهيتها
لغزا فوفقا لسي ان ان
خبراء بتقسيم السفن الى قسمين سفن رماديه
وهي التي قامت شركات وهميه بشرائها من
اوروبيين مع بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا وسفن اخرى سوداء ذات خبره
سابقه بتهريب او نقل النفط مع ايران
وفنزويلا لتجنب العقوبات الغربيه وتعتمد
على ايقاف تشغيل جهاز الارسال والاستقبال
الخاص لتجاوز عقبات الرصد والتتبع النفط
الروسي يتجاوز العقوبات والعقبات حتى دخل
الدول الاوروبيه كبريطانيا وجد طريقه عبر
الوسطاء فتظل مصافي النفط الهنديه
والصينيه مليئه بالخام الروسي ومن ثم
لاوروبا
عن السمان العربيه